donc bon soir on en avait parlé fin 2017
je vous avais promis qu'on ferait un
live début 2018 pour parler un petit peu
de cette nouvelle année qui s'annonce
pour romain pour moi et pour vous tous
pour dtc c'est parti pour le tout
premier live de l'histoire de dans ton
corps
[Musique]
donc comment ça va se passer on est
romain et moi ici tous les deux on est à
votre écoute robin et sur les réseaux
sociaux
à l'écouté de vos questions ou est-ce
que vous pouvez vous poser des questions
dans le chat donc delà de ce live
youtube sur twitter avec le hashtag
d'été fait live et je pense que c'est
déjà pas mal on va pas se disperser donc
twitter le chat vous poser les questions
que vous voulez et on y répond si on
veut voilà c'est là le truc alors
pourquoi est ce qu'on fait ce live comme
je vous l'avais expliqué fin 2017
il ya des choses qui vont changer en
2018 au niveau des formats au niveau
peut-être de la fréquence des vidéos
il ya tout un tas de choses qui vont
changer depuis le début on fait un peu
les choses en interaction avec vous donc
je me suis dit que c'était pas mal de
vous laisser un petit peu donnez votre
avis sur ce type d'évolution et puis
aussi autre truc qui m'a motivé c'est
que je reçois énormément de messages de
votre part malheureusement j'ai pas le
temps de répondre à tout le monde c'est
juste humainement pas possible ou alors
j'arrête de faire des vidéos mais du
coup c'est bizarre donc je me suis dit
que c'était pas mal de tout concentrer
en un seul endroit
un truc un peu plus vivant qu'une faq
enregistrés c'est à dire un truc
vraiment live vous vous posez vos
questions et je vous répond directement
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs quelque chose
qu'on peut être amené à renouveler
peut-être qu'il y en aura d'autres
peut-être que c'est le premier d'une
longue série voilà donc on attend vos
questions sur le tchat
on attend vos questions sur twitter avec
le hashtag dtc live et puis peut-être
qu'il ya déjà des premières questions
aux antilles sur curieuse cats avec ce
qu'on a à faire à qui on eu le cas aux
cathos s'ils étaient plus pour avoir des
trucs un petit peu en avance c'est pas
forcément la peine de retourner dessus
maintenant
contentez-vous du tchat et twitter ce
sera cool donc qu'est-ce qu'on a bâtie
il ya une question de gésiers de nos
canards exactement salutaire de connard
c'est combien de temps d'écriture d'un
épisode depuis l'idée du coc tournage
purement technique donc vraiment que
l'écriture
que l'écriture alors pour donner une
réponse chiffrée qui ne répondent pas
grand chose mais en je dirais entre une
journée et quatre jours une journée
c'est si c'est un sujet très simple très
ciblée très qui a déjà fait l'objet de
publications scientifiques je te donne
un exemple si je fais une vidéo sur
l'ongle incarné voilà c'est vraiment
quelque chose de super précis de super
identifié je vais avoir aucun mal à
trouver des informations là-dessus
donc ça c'est la classe et simple de
décrire
par contre si c'est une vidéo sur la
gueule de bois par exemple qui je pense
une des vidéos qui m'a pris le plus de
temps à écrire c'est pas vraiment
l'objet d'études scientifiques précises
c'est pas vraiment l'objet de
publications scientifiques précises et
puis c'est surtout plein de petits plein
de petites infos qui que je vais trouver
dans plein de publications différentes
du coup au lieu de consulter 4,5
document de faire une synthèse de
rajouter de la mise en scène des blagues
de vous remettre en forme pour que les
mots soient plus facilement
compréhensibles
là je vais être obligé d'aller chercher
dans deux lignes dans une publication
qui fait 10 pages puis de ligne dans un
autre truc et au bout du compte j'ai été
obligé consulter plein plein plein plein
de documents plus après rajouter toute
la mise en scène
les blagues les sketches les
interventions de renard et c'est donc là
ça peut être beaucoup plus longue donc
en gros à entre 1 et 4 jours disons mais
après le tournage s'est finalement c'est
assez rapide et le montage ça dépend de
ma forme alors on enchaîne dans les
questions d'enchères alors là il ya une
question je vais prendre celle de
florian a chuté et mais il ya mille
personnes connaît la question c'est ton
tatouage sur les fesses ça se passe
comment incroyable vraiment je n'avais
pas assez de canarder nova cette
question vous êtes plein de donc c'est
vraiment la question qu'on nous pose le
plus souvent
dans le métro on part tous ces fous donc
comment ça se passe d'abord vous le
saurez bientôt parce que je retourne
faire une séance de laser très bientôt
donc y aura une vidéo d'ici deux
semaines je crois donc on va en reparler
bientôt je vais refaire un petit point
d'ailleurs je pense à un truc un peu ça
fait maintenant longtemps que ça fait
plus d'un an que cette aventure est en
route
donc quand ça se passe pragmatiquement
bas ça bouge pas beaucoup
voilà un petit endroit où il ya vraiment
un trek a disparu mais c'est pas ouf
le reste ça atténue même pas tellement à
la une non non non donc c'est pas ouf
après je vais persévérer je suis pas je
suis pas inquiet voilà de toute façon du
compte ça restera mon tatouage sur bien
fait ce que je pourrais recouvrir le cas
échéant tenter d'autres trucs mais voilà
donc pour l'instant ça ne bouge pas
beaucoup et on va vraiment voir parler
très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo donc
je ne vous spoile pas ok alors une autre
question de fouad d'asie mais pourquoi
tu mets un nouveau t-shirt de groupe
mais n'a de groupes de métal dans chaque
vidéo et bosh qu'est-ce que alors grâce
à mon vieux alors pourquoi en fait c'est
c'est une espèce de rituel c'est un truc
je les fais pendant les deux trois
premiers épisodes
je me suis dit ou d'un moment qu'est ce
que je fais je continuais vraiment
acheter tee shirt je change le t-shirt à
chaque vidéo et voix je sais mon côté
peut-être un peu superstitieux
alors peut-être que les plus les plus
acharnés d'entre vous vont me ressortir
il doit y avoir deux trois tee shirt que
j'ai porté dans plusieurs dans plusieurs
des tcl mais sinon effectivement moi je
change de jeu mais un nouveau t-shirt à
chaque fois et aujourd'hui de tir
d'ailleurs si dans les commentaires
quelqu'un est capable de me dire le tee
shirt de quel groupe je porte
aujourd'hui je lui offre pas celui-là
parce qu'ils sont ma sueur mais je lui
recommande un jeu lure hockey bas coûts
s'est tu mais si c'est toi ça me
laissera pas non mais alors c'est que
moi lps comment et bien vous vous êtes
rencontre alors comment ces rencontres
avec romain j'imagine est ce que tu veux
répondre à cette question
non voilà roman est extrêmement timide à
la valeur les lignes alors on s'est
rencontrés chez 20 minutes
moi j'ai bossé là bas de 2008 à 2016
briques toi tu as aussi et là bas de
jambes ne me souviens plus réellement
c'était une année deux années et demie
deux années vraiment génial avec du lien
et cyprien et ses prières à l'époque
voilà on s'est rencontrés donc j'ai
vingt minutes
cyprien faisait une émission quotidienne
qui s'appelait le rewind dans laquelle à
l'époque où tu es arrivé je pense
j'intervenais la décharge mais ça n'a
pas été le cas tout de suite et moi je
suis venu pour être le monteur à la base
et voilà romain a été
embauchée pour soulager cyprien du
montage de cette émission quotidienne
dont quand même on est quand même sur
iphone c'est assez hardcore et est
progressivement
romain est passé derrière la caméra un
peu devant la caméra et puis beaucoup et
puis on a fait des sketches des voix là
et c'est un petit peu à la manière de ce
qu'on a ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui dans
dtc avec des voix off et des
interventions sur le dans le champ et
tout alla donc on s'est rencontrés
là-bas et j'ai eu envie de lancer
dtc c'est tout naturellement que je me
suis retourné vers moi ce que je sais
c'est tout naturellement que j'ai dit
oui évidemment carrément faire ce qu'ils
gagnent fortune aussi également là moi
j'adore trets par des makes alors autre
question bergame serdaigle pour qu'on
voit jamais romain voilà je suis d'un
rider que je suis là mais on entend une
voix grave malade et sous vos yeux
alors que tu profites c'est une petite
boule de timidité exergue la cfu on le
voit quand même oui revient
régulièrement
on va faire ridiculiser ne me parle pas
comme ça d'avoir des gens non non on l'a
tous vu dans plusieurs vidéos la vidéo
sur la prostate montre exactement la
vidéo sur le pénis
exactement je suis encore à mon avantage
un moyen bon match ici et dans la rue
pour avoir interprété le pénis avec
manière tout à fait crédible donc on le
voit parfois et si on voit pas plus
c'est peut-être parce qu'il n'y tiens
pas où exactement
nle alors j'en profite pour glisser une
petite et j'aimerais que tu que tu m'as
pitt c'est extrêmement souvent c'est à
dire à chaque fois en convention qu'on
pose alors motors plusieurs fois la
question pourquoi romain n'est pas là
donc maintenant vous avez la réponse
aidés parfois on engueule en le disant
vraiment tu tire la couverture à temps
on te voit tout le temps mais par contre
on voit jamais romain est ce que tu peux
dire aux gens qu'à chaque convention tu
me propose de venir me propose de venir
à chaque fois et à chaque fois j'ai dit
non voilà parce que j'ai une vie et
moi aussi j'ai une vie voilà c'est parce
que je voulais dire mais j'ai des choses
à faire et je peux n'a pas désiré vous -
caen et parce que je suis extrêmement
fluide on va continuer avec vos
questions je j'en profite
comme ça vous avez le temps de répondre
dans le chat ou sur twitter avec le
hashtag dtc live pour vous poser une
première petite question
parmi les messages très nombreux que
vous m'envoyez il ya beaucoup de
questions soient des questions sur des
cas perso qui concerne la santé soit des
questions sur des maladies des sujets
que vous aimeriez bien que le strait qui
alors hein c'est vraiment ce serait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop long de
répondre à tout le monde je le fais
parfois que je peux pas le faire tout le
temps al'inverse ça fait pas forcément
ça peut pas forcément faire l'objet
d'une vidéo complète parce que c'est la
réponse est très rapide du coup est ce
que vous seriez chaud pour qu'on fasse
ce type de live là par exemple mais sur
des questions autour de la santé s'avère
pas une faq détesté en tant que chaîne
youtube et unef
une faq santé une espèce de antenne
libre antenne où on parlerait de santé
où on parlera de leur attention en
sachant que je ne suis pas médecin donc
je ne ne peux pas faire de diagnostic et
je peut pas prescrire de traitement
c'est globalement la grosse différence
entre un médecin infirmier c'est ça un
médecin il fait un diagnostic c'est à
dire à partir de ce qu'on lui raconte
des signes qu'ils voient et des examens
qui demande au patient il dit ok
manifestement mon diagnostic c'est que
vous avez telle maladie moi je peux pas
faire ça c'est pas mon métier et une
fois qu'il a fait ça il dit je vous
prescris tel traitement pour soigner la
maladie que je vous ai diagnostic et
donc il fait une ordonnance moi je ne
peux pas faire ça voilà donc moi je peux
pas faire de consultation je peux pas
donner de conseils médicaux parce que je
ne suis pas médecin
par contre on peut parler santé
au sens voilà beaucoup plus large du
terme comme on le fait un peu sur des pc
donc ma question est ce que vous seriez
chaud pour que de temps en temps en face
des live autour de sujets de santé donc
vous répondez s'il vous plaît dans le
chat est sûre et sur twitter avec le
hashtag d'été fait live et en attendant
on continue à répondre à votre question
question alors sur twitter il ya lui
très bien voilà qui demande tu est un
fermier pendant combien de temps
qu'est ce qui t'a motivé et pourquoi
as-tu arrêté alors j'ai été interviewé a
été interviewé cette semaine par
l'infirmière magazine et par
infirmiers.com qui sont deux sites
professionnels dans lesquels je détaille
pas mal mon parcours d'un fermier
n'hésitez pas si c'est vraiment ça vous
intéresse acheter un oeil vous aurez
toutes les réponses
j'étais infirmier pendant combien de
temps j'étais infirmier pendant 10 ans
pour la faire courte s'étend en réa samu
un an et demi un chat mais à domicile un
an et demi infirmiers par téléphone ça
existe vous irez vers les articles si
vous voulez voir à quoi ça correspond
qu'est-ce qui va motiver rien je suis
tombé dedans vraiment par hasard je vais
commencer une fac de langues que j'ai
arrêté très vite pour un faire la fête
avec mes potes et au bout d'un moment je
me suis dit faut je reprenne mes études
et ma soeur à ce moment là elle passe le
concours d'infirmière je dis vraiment un
dossier j'ai passé le concours je les ai
eus je suis devenu infirmier et c'était
génial je veux que tu restes pas dix ans
par hasard je suis devenu affaire départ
hasard mais je suis resté parce que
samassa ma beauté voilà il y avait une
deuxième partie peut-être la question et
puis aussi le trio qui a fait avec pour
le podcast sur nos tubes nos tubes enfin
sur nos tubes
oui vous pouvez aller écouter ça aussi
on parle pas mal de trucs là et c'est je
vous conseille d'ailleurs le podcast
youtube qui est qui est super
intéressant moins qu'elle
quand c'est des interventions de
créateurs vraiment vincent qui est le
nid matters de ce podcast prend le temps
de creuser les trucs c'est hyper
intéressant il en a fait récemment avec
pv nova je crois qu'ils très chouette
tout ce qu'il a fait avant sont très
chouette aussi quand il a des invités
prend le temps d'en discuter quand il
parle de thématiques c'est toujours
fouillées documenté intéressant donc si
vous aimez youtube podcast nos tubes
mettez vous bien il ya eu go d'échelle
sur twitter qu'il demande est ce que vos
mecs
non non ce que tu comptes refaire une
vidéo qui te mets dans la peau de
quelqu'un comme je l'avais fait pour les
personnes âgées par exemple les aveugles
ou les sourds et ben alors est ce que tu
peux en le ps ps vous êtes géniaux l'a
fait mais l'important fin c'est assez
faux mais c'est très gentil
alors non je compte parfaite je devrais
je pense pas mais je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
en fait j'en ai fait une donc
effectivement je mets deux mettait dans
la peau d'une personne âgée avec une
combinaison qui limitaient les
mouvements la vision l'audition etc
après ça on m'a proposé de tester plein
d'autres combinaisons de ce genre
testez être une femme enceinte tester
être avoir un handicap physique tester
ton fauteuil roulant machin etc et et ça
m'a mis mal à l'aise de me dire en fait
pourquoi est-ce que moi en tant que
personne qui ne vit pas la situation
je vais mettre dans la situation pour
raconter comment ça fait pourquoi plutôt
je n'invite pas des gens qui sont
vraiment dans la situation pour raconter
comment ça fait et c'est comme ça que la
série dans son corps est né c'est à dire
que j'invite des gens qui ont vraiment
des particularités physiques comme comme
on dit dans le jargon
ce soit maladie handicap du plus léger
au plus lourd et reviennent nous
raconter ce que ça fait en tout cas de
leur point de vue et surtout comment ils
ont appris à vivre avec donc gg je
préfère laisser la parole aux gens qui
savent vraiment ce que c'est que de
faire semblant de le ressentir moi-même
et de vous parler voilà donc non je
pense que je le ferai plus ok alors vous
il ya plein de questions toc toc toc
alors il ya surtout l'odeur 4 oui c'est
moche c'est à mon sens très saine
bonjour lorsque vous avez des sujets
spécifiques sur la santé où trouvez-vous
les réponses
n'avez vous pas peur de vous tromper
dans l'information diffusée dans les
vidéos c'était beaucoup de questions en
une seule voilà est-ce que j'ai peur de
me tromper d écoute si j'avais pas peur
de me tromper je ferai pas les efforts
nécessaires pour ne pas me tromper
donc oui j'ai peur de me tromper voilà
ça aussi fait partie des rares cas où la
peur peut éviter le danger
donc j'ai peur de me tromper du coup je
fais tout pour pas me tromper et je suis
pas infaillible donc potentiellement je
me suis déjà trompé ou jeu
le tromperait y'a pas de soucis où je
vais chercher les informations dans des
publications scientifiques sur des sites
d'institutions
au près c'est objectivement assez rare
mais auprès de spécialistes
c'est à dire des médecins des chercheurs
et c'est là la question de la fiabilité
des sources c'est vraiment une très
vaste question il se trouve que après
avoir été infirmier j'ai été journaliste
donc c'est typiquement le genre de truc
que tu apprends un peu à l'école et
surtout dans sa pratique quotidienne
c'est à dire savoir repérer les sources
fiables pas se contenter d'une soeur
d'une seule source mais croiser un peu
tes sources et c'est ce qui fait qu'au
bout d'un moment tu te dis ok là je
raconte des trucs qui potentiellement se
sont avérées après tu peux toujours te
tromper dans une interprétation dans une
façon de formuler les choses tu peux
être moi donc je suis pas infaillible
de toute façon ne faut pas prendre ce
que je dis ni ce que personne ne dit
pour argent comptant
je pense que l'intérêt des vidéos du
lias station scientifique ou de toute
autre vie des vidéos pédagogiques sur
youtube c'est de vous donner une
première info 12 éveiller votre
curiosité
si ça vous intéresse il faut aller faut
aller creuser quoi voilà alors vatin
beaucoup de questions encore une fois
donc tout toc toc toc
anthony ces tickets demande est ce que
tu sais que ce que tu fais c'est génial
que ces voix là on a les moyens gentil
c'est très cool génial franchement je ne
sais pas mais parce que le génie je
pense que c'est quelques crans au dessus
de ce qu'on fait est ce que je
est ce que je sais que ce qu'on fait
c'est cool
j'espère vraiment
l'idée c'était de lancer un truc marrant
informatif est à la fois préventif et
qui ouvre un peu l'esprit sur la
condition des autres sur la différence
être malade
du lieu
la peut-être sans prétention aucune mais
si ça peut apprendre aux gens un peu à
vivre ensemble avec des lampes sont pas
forcément exactement comme eux voient
donc à notre petite échelle j'espère
qu'on arrive à faire ça donc je suis si
la question c'est est-ce que je suis
fier de ce qu'ont fait la réponse est
oui je suis assez fier c'est perfectible
mais je suis bien content de ce qu'ont
fait très bien alors il ya une question
de dd l'assad en [ __ ] castaing jours
aa alors j'en profite pour saluer
flaubert et mon frère adrien je passerai
dans le flot de castin jours ci
contrairement à la dernière fois
puisque j'ai enregistré un trou de caste
si les micro fonctionne
voilà moi je suis un grand fan de flou
caste jeu les coûts tout en faisant du
sport ce qui est hyper dangereux ne
faites pas ça chez vous parce que
vraiment je me fais péter les dents
plusieurs fois en faisant des pompes et
en ayant une quinte de rire je suis un
énorme fan du foot caste j'étais ravi
que flaubert d'un vite j'étais très
désappointé que notre notre épisode ne
soit pas en ligne parce que le son était
trop pourri donc si flaubert ne rien
vite j'y retourne et donc du coup oui
j'espère que je serai de nouveau dans
flickr son nom génial parfait à une
formation d'animateur et je suis
totalement à fond dedans benoît bonjour
julien a tué mais participer aux frênes
festival à avignon bonne continuation
globalement j'aime beaucoup les
conventions les festoche de youtube
heures etc
je trouve ça toujours super cool de
mettre des visages sur des pseudos ou
de voir en vrai qui vous êtes
je trouve ça vraiment ça fait super
démago ans j'ai bien conscience de dire
ça mais c'est vrai en fait j'aime
vraiment de base j'aime bien rencontrer
les gens je pense c'est pour ça que
j'étais infirmier je pense c'est pour ça
que j'étais journaliste et du coup
aujourd'hui c'est un peu frustrant en
vrai d'avoir l'impression de parler à
plein de gens mais on devrait de parler
tout le temps un objectif de 2 caméras
avec une personne barbus derrière
du coup quand je vois des gens en vrai
je trouve ça cool donc globalement
j'aime beaucoup le fremm festival j'aime
particulièrement
d'abord parce que les gens qui
l'organisent sont extrêmement
sympathique la vraie orga et les
parrains du truc qui sont patrick boos
françois thorel a etc
ensuite parce que avignon magnifique et
pour finir parce que c'est un vrai
festival qui a du sens ce qui te donne
un peu carte blanche pour faire des
trucs sang s'écoule qui vont un peu au
delà des questions habituelles
du coup le public est à la hauteur le
public c'est des gens qui sont qui
diffère un peu des gens que tu peux
croiser d'habitude même si je trouve ça
cool de croiser tous types de gens mais
celui de frappe vraiment il ya cette
particularité là et puis voilà c'est
vraiment un truc
la ville d'avignon c'est magnifique les
lieux où il ya toutes les interventions
sont vraiment chouettes on passe
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment cool j'ai suivi
un petit truc oui il ya des gens qui se
plaignent du son qui à droite et à
gauche
c'est notre premier live ya eu un petit
loupé et on enverra le mec qui se
souvient c'est faux et c'est évidemment
faux et on remercie celui qui est oui et
l'amour
merci derrière ces écrans oui bah les
problèmes là soient gérés sont ces mêmes
dans les vidéos de dtc vous oui les
sirènes fixes pour la polluant virale mx
air faussement quandalle boum boum boum
alors après d'ailleurs en parlant ça
doit faire chaud au coeur de voir de sam
qui dit oh wow racaille bourahli cas
voilà une plante je ne comptais félicite
du succès de l'été ces équipes il y
surtout garde romain c'est un bon lui
donc c'est tout plu à dire parfois que
cowell par les occidentaux qui est bien
alors après il ya mathias qui demande
iron man iron maiden ou black sabbath à
quoi papa ou maman
non ce qui me concerne les deux sont
morts voilà c'était l'instant malaise
jeu
iron maiden parce que c'est le premier
groupe que j'ai vraiment écouté c'est le
premier groupe que j'ai vu en live
donc voilà iron maiden et inch'allah je
retourne le voir du côté de clis un
genre il ya monsieur habib qui dit qui
demande que lui dire quoi par mettez
vous bien à la fin de chaque épisode
ah ben c'est une très bonne question je
veux dire ce que tu as envie de
comprendre se mettre bien en fait ça
veut dire c'est c'est indissociable de
portez vous bien en fait c'est mettez
vous bien et portez vous bien parce que
bien se porter ça veut dire être en
bonne santé
plutôt physique bien se mettre
c est en bonne santé plutôt mental et
pour moi les deux on a déjà parlé dans
une vidéo si vous l'avez vu les deux
sont indissociables donc mettez vous
bien ça veut dire faites vous plaisir de
la manière qui vous convient le mieux et
portez vous bien il ya toujours un
équilibre
bizarrement c'est moche mais tout ce qui
te fait plaisir mentalement
psychologiquement a facilement tendance
à te mettre mal physiquement que ce soit
la bouffe que ce soit
la boisson que ce soit voilà tout ce que
tu tout ce que tu peux imaginer mais ça
reste important parfois de se dire ok
est ce que je suis en train de faire là
c'est pas idéal
d'un point de vue la santé physique par
contre vraiment ça va mettre tellement
bien que du coup ça va finalement
globalement contribué à ma santé
personnelle donc met toi bien & porte
toi bien trouver l'équilibré entre ce
qui te fait plaisir et qui te fait pas
trop de mal
et voilà l'arrière personnes qui
demandent c'est un fonds vient derrière
non bien sûr que non quand on est dans
un nez dans le xvième actuellement dans
le 16e arrondissement de paris on est
avenue hoche
on est dans un cabinet de ces combien sa
romance et 345 mètres carrés je crois
tout étant une carte est en marbre
s'échauffer s'échauffent à chaleur le
solde quoi voilà oui c'est un fond vert
évidemment c'est un frère et un arc avec
la question d'adria belmas qui demande à
quand un nouveau décor alors j'ai une
réponse à une question
la réponse c'est j'en sais rien et ma
question c'est pourquoi un nouveau décor
je vous laisse je le sais que ça moi
j'aime bien ce décor là peut-être
qu'effectivement un jour on n'en
changera pas ce que vous avez assuré 0
ce soit au niveau de ma blouse au niveau
des textes najjar et c'est peut-être
qu'un jour il faudra en changer
en vrai j'aime bien celui-là c'est comme
le générique peut-être j'anticipe une
question me pose souvent la question est
est ce que tu vas changer de génériques
un jour j'aime beaucoup le générique la
musique qui était composée par wax juste
pour nous et encore merci je vais
beaucoup le l'espèce de côté un peu
clips et de photos
je trouve très cool aussi donc pour
l'instant tout à moi ça me plaît
toujours apprécié vous demande de me dit
vous êtes 436 milles à me dire vraiment
ça sous le change on y réfléchira mais
pour l'instant j'ai pas envie parfait
alors est-ce qu'on a des questions de
type de rôle j'ai l'impression qu'on est
beaucoup moins là dans le sérieux à ce
qu'on a pas mal de questions sérieuses
atteintes à ce que tout à l'heure je
voyais des trucs drôles passé
non mais vas-y vas-y tout ou alors il ya
du sérieux c'est soit tu fais là
d'interventions dans les écoles pour
aborder les tabous médicaux waouh
vraiment merci parce que je suis réclamé
du lol c'est un peu troublant les suites
est ce que je compte faire des
interventions dans les écoles alors
d'abord c'est pas vraiment
moi qui décide si on me propose pourquoi
pas je viens de voter
je vais être transparents et vous gêne t
faire des interventions dans les écoles
ouais pourquoi pas pour parler des
tabous en vrai c'est chaud j'en parle
dans mes vidéos un peu des fois je de
route et les releveurs vient de recevoir
un sms qu'il est en train de lire avec
les pros en fait je crois que suis plus
à l'aise
l'idée de faire des vidéos qui parle de
tabou et que des instit ou des profs ça
existe plusieurs types des profs d'école
ou des profs de collège ou quoi prenne
la responsabilité la décision de montrer
à leurs élèves ou pas que des parents
prennent la décision et la
responsabilité de montrer à leurs
enfants ou pas je suis plus à l'aise
avec sac avec l'idée de me pointer
devant des
une heure et de leur parler de trucs
tabou je rejoins ce n'est pas à moi de
le faire
en tout cas c'est pas à moi de décider
s'ils sont aptes à l'entendre donc alors
jeune avec aussi de bavay nous besoin il
est très très fort sur le super à 2
millions et à une totale donc j'ai pas
je vraiment si on me propose de le faire
pourquoi pas mais spontanément je n'ai
pas vocation à aller par les tabous dans
l'est dans les écoles ok alors il ya
pergame serdaigle qui demande encore
l'uscri front door serpentard sert dead
ou poufsouffle alors je vais être franc
avec vous je n'ai pas vu je crois un
seul harry potter en entier pour une
raison qui est très simple c'est que
j'ai à je suis atteint d'une sorte de
mal ou de malédiction ou de maladies ne
sais pas ce que c'est c'est que tu me
poses sur un canapé et tu m'en empêche
de parler pendant plus deux
dix minutes et je m'endors mais vraiment
donc j'ai beaucoup de mal à voir des
films surtout le soir
mais comme les films je les regarde
plutôt le soir du coup j'ai vraiment du
mal à regarder des films sauf si je les
regarde en journée du coup tous les
harry potter je les ai commencé j'ai une
fille qui s'appelle l'ena que j'embrasse
qui est une fan hardcore de harry potter
et qui fait qu a vraiment insisté pour
me montrer tous les films mais c'est
vrai qu'elle était très déçu de voir que
je m'endormais à chaque fois voilà donc
je ne sais pas je j'ai envie de dire
quoi tout souffle c'est les gentils mais
un peu con succès n'a rien d'accord
serpentard c'est les méchants mais super
déterminé gryffondor c'est la maison de
harry potter et champagne et c'est le
voilà j'aime pas trop harry potter ans
que j'en ai vu vraiment si ça m'a l'air
d'être un sacré suce boules et il ya
quoi dotia serdaigle c'est réglé serdex
c est courageux et qui est un peu en
retrait quoi ouais bah serdaly cinq ans
cédric nord alors tu parles de ta fille
alors ya une question ses vidéos milieu
c'est ton fils vidéos milieu du coup
alors merci de me tendre la perche c'est
mon fils que j'embrasse aussi même si je
pense qu'il est pas du tout en train de
regarder ce qu'il a bien mieux à faire
c est tant mieux
oui c'est mon fils voilà parfait il ya
loin robert ce test qui demandent est ce
que fut le sien avoir remarqué qu'il y
avait écrit what the fuck et ptdr 20
plaintes notamment à l'arrière
je peux pas l'affirmer mais dans la
mesure où on a dansé deux ans presque
non ça fait un an et demi un peu plus
d'un an et demi qu'on fait des vidéos
ont fait une par semaine voire des fois
deux par semaine dans la mesure où il ya
systématiquement une dizaine de
commentaires soient chacune 2
vidéo qui dit est ce que je suis le seul
alors remarqué qu'il y avait eu un bug
et ptdr sur le truc ophtalmo derrière je
pense pouvoir dire que non j'ai où les
tombes dont celle ci n'est pas le seul
vraiment chez par groupe et vous
discuter entre vous mais manifestement
vous êtes nombreux à penser que vous
êtes seul et c'est triste
finalement qui vous êtes très nombreux
voilà alors pareil j'en profite pour
faire un petit je vais faire mon coming
out
oui vraiment dans ton corps d'été c'est
dans ton cul c'est fait exprès voilà
vous pouvez arrêter de faire cette
blague maintenant vous pouvez arrêter de
diarra c'est marrant parce que ça fait
aussi dans ton cul je suis au courant
voilà c'était marrant les 2/3 première
fois mais là vraiment vraiment content
tous deux en cellule deux ans vraiment
je peux vous le dire maintenant
oui je les fais exprès parfait alors
autre question toc toc toc
ah oui bah est répondre le moment femme
qui brille ça serait cool que tu fasses
des vidéos et le dr nordmann mais
techniquement ça a été déjà fait j'ai
fait une vidéo avec dr nordmann mais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu particulier
c'était pour parler de son de sa
particularité physique à l'uc et le
syndrome de la toi tu après faire des
vidéos peut-être plus
dans l'esprit de celle qui fait dans
l'esprit de celle que je fais moi mais
où vraiment ont fait une vraie collab
pourquoi pas j'ai fait assez peu de
vrais collab en mouvement fait justement
il ya une autre question qui dira que tu
as prévu des call avec d'autres youtuber
santé comme des non nationaux se
prénomme nasser est par exemple
exactement pourquoi pas j'ai pas prévu
je suis pas spontanément je sais pas un
truc qui me vient facilement à l'esprit
mais pourquoi pas je suis pas du tout
opposé
que ce soit avec asklepios avec primondo
serré avec docteur norman avec sa nana
ce que sais-je jeu
pourquoi pas avec ma claque et carlito
pourquoi pas je ne sais pas je suis ça
pour être chouette mais de faire des
vrais crossover du coup ne sert vraiment
un truc où on mélange les univers
oui non c'est rien c'est peut-être j'ai
failli dire une autre question excusez
moi pardon je me suis laissé perturber
par là il est très très très volatile à
je suis vraiment top top ça bien qu'il
vienne 10 jon rauch ton conseil pour
choper sur kindle a alors tu es vraiment
très très bien tomber parce que c'est ma
spécialité vraiment choqué sur teen d'or
c'est ma spécialité vraiment non jeu
jamais étais sûr qu aucune appli de
rencontre donc non je ne sais pas
peut-être mon conseil pour choper nom va
voir des valeurs des tutos je suis sûr
que y en a eu 20 des milliers quoi alors
peut-être ne met pas une photo d nikos
sous les ongles de pieds en photo de
profil
ça me paraît bien notés sur vend pas
parce que ça va se voir que tu as menti
à un moment ou un autre
voilà jeunes vraiment je mens je peux
pas t'aider parfait d'un appareil non
pas parfait alors une question de clara
père est à l'amp est repéré par an chez
totalement nuls peux-tu te tatouer la
tête de romain sur l'autre fesses oui
vraiment oui oui
en aucune façon clara vraiment ce que je
mange déjà mon pain noir avec avec cyril
avec ce bon vieux syrie là mais peut
être pas parce que c'est romain mais je
viens me fait attribuer au plus personne
sur aucune fesses de mon corps corentin
le doubs les gens te confronte il
toujours avec mon frère un ébat de moins
en moins vraiment
c'est bah c'est arrivé je crois la
dernière fois où vraiment ça a été
flagrant c était justement ofgem
festival donc ça remonte un peu dans cet
élan en septembre début septembre où un
mec très cool m'aborde dans la rue me
fait super génial on peut faire un seul
filet touche bien sur mac et enfin celle
fillon fait un self y discute des
minutes et à la fin le mec me fait ça
lui et puis vraiment alors le truc
le mec qu'on écoute jamais dans les
films de lanus âge super à tous donc
voilà lui c'était le dernier
après peut-être qu'il ya des gens qui
viennent me voir et qui me disent ah
mettez le mec de youtube j'aime beaucoup
ce que tu fais peut-être qu'en vrai y
parle pas du tout de moi et par le
moufia s'est pas mis physiquement ni
artistiquement je sentirai insulté
d'être confondus avec mon frère il se
trouve que c'est plutôt physiquement
mais plutôt pour gosses donc leur avance
ça me va bien
mais même si c'est artistiquement sais
je suis un fan de mon frère donc avec
plaisir
il ya une question à part la nuit
original oui c est ce que tu refais des
vidéos de roland ou du genre qui avait
fait lors d'une nuit original je pense
m'être le quiz tout à fait que nico
alors j'ai fait toutes les nuits
originale jai pas à chaque fois eu un
règlement je n'ai pas à chaque fois
animer une tranche mais j'ai fait toutes
les nuits original depuis le début est
ce que j'y retournerai béjaouis
volontiers après c'est bien aussi que ça
tourne qui n'est pas toujours les mêmes
têtes c'est la volonté de aussi de
thomas r couette qui est le papa de la
nuit original mais j'y retourne toujours
avec plaisir
ne serait ce que pour me mettre bien
avec les copains alors là c'est un peu
délaissé twitter mais 1,1 kg alexis
white qui demande sinon en casquette
gate tu as choisi quoi à casquette gates
est en gros j'ai un gros souci quand je
mets une casquette
j'ai plusieurs j'ai beaucoup de
casquettes que j'aime beaucoup et quand
je mets une casquette systématiquement
je l'enlève d'une coupe de merde
donc je ne sais pas est ce que j'arrête
de mettre des casquettes ou est-ce que
je mets des casquettes mais je ne
l'enlève jamais où est ce que je
dit tant pis je m'en fous j'ai une coupe
de merde alors j'ai choisi de continuer
avec mes casquettes et de les garder
toute la journée toute la soirée
pour pas avoir une coupe de merde voix
ok tout cas alors je vois une question à
laquelle je vais répondre en épisodes
prévus sur les personnes transgenres et
transsexuels
oui absolument c'est elle est en cours
d'écriture depuis un petit moment
maintenant la fin d'année début d'année
là c'est un peu un peu speed mais oui
oui c'est un sujet qui je vais aborder
sous l'angle santé parce que c'est mon
credo mais c'est un sujet qui dépasse
largement
c'est cette thématique là donc je veux
vraiment faire les choses de manières
carré donc je prends mon temps mais oui
c'est ça sera même probablement dans les
semaines les deux mois qui viennent je
veux pas m'avancer mais oui bien sûr
c'est président et je l'avais
effectivement plus ou moins promis donc
chose promise chose due et du coup je
fais une petite digression mais comme
j'en avais parlé au moment où j'avais
annoncé ce live fin d'année début
d'année l'ag a notamment un projet qui
me prend pas mal de temps dont je ne
peux pas trop parler mais pareil dans
les mois qui viennent vous saurez
donc je suis un peu moins présent mais
c'était aussi de toute façon la période
des fêtes donc ça c'est comme tous les
ans potentiellement peut-être encore
janvier et février il y aura peut-être
pas des vidéos toutes les semaines ça a
été assez nombreux à me dire en vrai fed
et des vidéos quand tu veuilles a pas il
n'y a pas obligation à faire toute la
semaine
j'aime bien quand même le rythme avec
d'eau donc et puis j'ai tellement de
sujets à traiter que voilà mais
peut-être encore pendant quelques
semaines ça va être un peu irrégulier
voilà d'accord alors je reviens de temps
car le sens que la mecque les affaires
la rime et sur les approuvent mais pour
les nouvelles personnes qui arrivent oui
un petit problème de son mais c'est
juste cette fois là et la prochaine fois
on se rattrapera promis
donc même été deux casques sinon les
deux oreilles gauche n'en sera pas il ya
ludovic desprez qui dit je viens de
finir si office je sais quoi maintenant
à tresques
alors tu viens de finir les offices
croit us
une new yorkais ou français qu'il y
avait aussi la nation avec lb relais on
était enfant alors us uk
tu fais quoi tu fais globalement tu fais
tu prends une série anglaise et tu te
fais toutes les saisons et c'est un tout
seul il n'y aura pas de souci donc si tu
as fait et office le duo est tu fais
office uk
sinon tu fais misfits si tu connais pas
sinon tu fais le look 6 si tu connais
pas sinon tu fais dit haïti crowd si tu
connais pas sinon tu fais i and of the
fucking world si tu connais pas et si
t'aime pas les anglais laisse moi
tranquille
donc c'était faisable il ya plein de
séries cool
voilà mes brûlures le truc alors il ya
julien pierre et qu'ils demandent c'est
vrai j'ai déjà prêtes à leur tour sinon
tu fais park chan reec
comme ça c'est pas anglais mais c'est à
y remédier aux fils pourrais-tu faire
des nouvelles vidéos pour nous apprendre
à sauver des vies comme le sauvetage de
la croix rouge
mais ça on verra bien sûr le programme
on comprend que tu feras oui voilà c'est
tout oui pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas je les ferai sans doute
différemment je ferai peut-être des
trucs sur les bébés notamment huawei
pourquoi pas là c'est pas prévu dans les
prochaines mais en ce jour très
probablement derrière elle beaucoup
qu'il main sur tout et tee shirt c'est
quoi ton vous préférez alors en plus de
mon mal mystérieux qui fait que je
m'endors au bout de dix minutes si on
m'a soi et qu'on empêche de parler j'ai
un autre mâle qui est pour le coup un
peu plus répandue c'est que je ne ne
sait pas choisir
du coup quand tu me demande ce que c'est
mon truc préféré talus pour les séries
stand n 12 quand tu me demande mon truc
préféré vraiment j'ai l'impression
forcément de trahir quelqu'un ou de
faire de la peine à quelqu'un même si
c'est un tee shirt je suis un fragile
donc je j'ai pas de groupes préférés
gej j'aime énormément
soucy d'olten d'annecy vraiment beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup cro mag j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup ultra vomit tu et voilà
ça va ta voix grave et viril c'est
naturel de guet-ndar alors ma voix grave
et viril
c'est un peu naturel parce que j'ai
toujours eu la voix grave c'est un peu
accidentelle parce que et il faut que je
consulte pour ça j'ai fait du rugby
pendant longtemps et je me suis pris ce
qu'on appelle une cravate
c'est à dire un plaquage très austère un
coup d'avant bras dans la dans le niveau
de la pomme d'adam
en fait j'ai pas pu parler pendant trois
jours et ensuite j'ai repris ma voix
peut-être un peu plus grave et surtout
avec une impossibilité de poussé dans
les aigüs r avant j'étais capable de
crier de façon non très très très aigu
et maintenant je suis plus du tout une
capable je sais j'ai même relativement
du mal à crier très fort maintenant donc
je pense qu'il s'est passé un truc au
niveau de mes cordes vocales
je pense que ce serait vraiment très
bien jallieu faire regarder sa part
arnaud hurel genre avec une petite
caméra de type fibroscopie peut-être
même que je ferai une vidéo pour que
vous voyez mes cordes vocales et sera
peut-être l'occasion de vous expliquer
comment ça fonctionne la vois ton combat
mais voilà ma voix était de grave de
base est encore plus grave est
actuellement je ne fume pas j'ai se vit
ce qui est de
dessus mais parfois mais en ce moment je
ne fume pas donc par contre je suis
malade
il ya alors atteinte au tout une
question de nicolas lazer diva va bien
la première devait subir les ont alors
vous faites c'est la cesse et le
beausset est-ce que ça là c est ce que
tu as c'est nicolas nicolas mardi qu la
place à nicolas d'accord et le stc le
début de la question exactement
j'apprends à lire avec toi c'est fait
des progrès pour ce brave est ce que
julien pense que prendre des vidéos
d'interviews comme à l'époque de 20
minutes
franck simard et veiller sur un monde
internet à moi je presse j ai vraiment
pensé au début je les ai même proposé à
des gens qui étaient intéressés ou pas
je n'ai pas fait parce que j'avais pas
le temps parce que je voulais me
concentrer sur dtc et puis maintenant il
ya tube par guillem et pierre lapin qui
est pas exactement la même chose mais
qui quand même reprend le même ça ça
ferait vraiment doublons donc j'ai fait
mon temps je laisse la place aux jeunes
et et puis voilà non donc non je pense
pas parfait et alors l'élection sur le
cerveau oui il y en a un qui demande à
quai par qu'un cerveau sur la table
c'est celui de renault exactement
d'ailleurs le glisse bien d'abord il la
prime et la famille ils demandent où tu
l'as acheté donc c'est
je n'entends pas du tout je les achetais
je les achetais dans le 10e dans un
magasin de déguisements farces et
attrapes machin ça doit être c'est paru
dufour poissonnière mais c'est une rue
parallèle
donc voilà enfin vous voyez bien où ça
se passe tous ses petits magasins ne
pour les parisiens en tout cas donc
voilà non cette info il ya eu une fois
un vrai cerveau dans des esprits dans
l'épisode sur la gueule de bois que
j'avais été acheté chez un médecin
légiste
donc j'avais été acheté chez un boucher
c'est une cervelle d'agneau juste avant
le juste avant le tournage et qu'on
avait c'était je crois que c'était un
tourneur vendredi et on avait laissé on
est jetés après la cervelle d'agneau
dans la poubelle et on avait eu des
remords
en élevant notre bière de fin de
tournage en dix ans potentiellement la
femme de ménage ne va pas passer avant
lundi et potentiellement 7 cervelle
sentira très mauvais après avoir passé
le week-end dans la on n'a pas eu de
nouvelles chutes qantas ne mettait pas à
l'aide si la femme de ménage voici naïve
mais agissent y aller nous voilà déjà
pardon pour avancer on s'excuse et après
il ya des oies cap et blake qui demande
romain est ce que tu te venge au rcam
qui devra se passer pour un noob
non parce que je suis effectivement
salariés paient trop peur de perdre mon
emploi en fait donc voilà est ce que est
ce que dante notamment sur
sur twitter est ce que les gens se
prononce sur potentiellement le fait de
faire des lives de façon régulière et
fiction tous super chaud ils sont tous
super chaunois c'était d'accord et voilà
c'est parti kwa dans tout le monde est
super chaud pour les live et beaucoup de
personnes ont répondu pour ton t-shirt a
alors laissé répond non mais va-t-il dis
moi quelle sont les quelles sont les
réponses légal et kawaï mokaké grande
envie tiello viens de dire vous craquez
j'espère que monique regarde ce live
monique que j'embrasse ce que je sais
que tu es une fille j'aime beaucoup
j'espère que je vais vous voyez
d'ailleurs parce que je veux m'excuser
monique c'est la maman de robots monique
ou faire que de regarder sly truc que
vous êtes fier de robin et j'espère même
que vous savez pas ce que c'est qu'un
[ __ ] mais que vous allez regarder
crise sur google donc ça s'écrit bu2 caa
tient bon en brasse monique donc c'est
un t-shirt kawaii [ __ ] j'ai beaucoup
turcot répondu beaucoup de gens qui ont
répondu dans le chat dans le tchat sur
tout et sur twitter
alors je suis désolé pour ceux qui ont
répondu sur le tchat je regarde leur île
et 18h49 je ferai un tirage au sort dans
les gens qui ont répondu sur twitter
avant 18h49 et j'enverrai un tricheur
pas celui là encore une fois j'enverrai
un t-shirt kawaii [ __ ] à aux gagnants
ou à la gagnante
je prendrai contact avec toi d'abord
pour que tu me donnes pas taillé de tee
shirt bien sûr suis lassé du web se fait
lui-même ont fait un petit peu attention
on est il nous reste 10 minutes
globalement je voudrais pas prévenu mais
ce live dure une heure et nous reste une
dizaine de minutes je vais puisque
apparemment vous avez vous avez l'air
d'être assez chaud sur le sur le sur les
live dans les nouveaux formats qui vont
potentiellement arriver sur sur des t c
est un truc qui devrait arriver
peut-être cette année je vais pas trop
m'avancer parce que je veux pas faire
mon gars qui cadencent des trucs et
qu'il ne fait pas mais tu as un truc
autour de tester des trucs
voilà déjà peut-être vous pouvez me dire
toujours sur avec le hashtag dtc live
durant le chat si des trucs plus des
trucs sur le terrain peut-être plus des
trucs improvisé et - cascades
même si on garde ce format là et si on
garde dans son corps et combien de tout
le reste mais si en plus bas plus de
formation de terrain plus de tests de
trucs en conditions réelles
ça peut vous intéresser deuxième
question là ce sera vraiment pour dans
un deuxième temps parce que c'est des
trucs qui nécessite beaucoup de
préparation mais je l'avais déjà évoqué
aussi dans la vidéo de décembre est ce
que un truc du type fiction donc mon
credo mon dada c'est plutôt l'humour on
a un truc tu le sais toi même une
fiction d'humour autour de l'univers de
la santé
est ce que c'est un truc qui peut vous
soucier est ce que c'est un truc qui
peut vous soucier sur dtc voilà c'était
pas pareil à ma me donnez votre avis
là-dessus j'ai très envie de le faire de
toute façon je pense que je vais le
faire est ce que je le fais sur dtc ou
est-ce que je vais me faire voir
ailleurs je évidemment je ferais mais
votre avis votre avis m'importe donc
n'hésitez pas
à nous dire ça donc on fait les
dernières questions
oui c'est la sté messager qui demande
une vidéo avec les mii alors non parce
qu'il est mort alors si on parle de lait
liquide mister j'ai bien peur que ce ne
soit pas possible
alimi le squelette si on parle à une
amie le squelette qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle lamy qui est juste la voix là
bas toutes les vidéos avec les mythes
bien sûr et si on parle de l'emi onas du
russe qui est je crois qu'il dit dans le
connecticut qui tiennent petit droguerie
vraiment impliqué le maire de magnac
vraiment n'a aucun intérêt
voilà je viens vous dire non tout de
suite mais en plus il n'est pas traité
troll je sais pas j'ai pas chaud il ya
une question de diallo c'est qu'ils
question qui me donne pour romain pour
moi en même temps mais tue en moyenne
pour monter une vidéo
ça dépend vraiment des vidéos réellement
mais fuit extrêmement doué donc c'est
super rapide à chaque fois c'est
incroyable des doux et très rapidement
avec chloé c'est pas possible
donc voilà elle mais ça dépend des
vidéos ça dépend des effets tu vas
encore quelqu'un c'est lui et non non je
ne donnerais pas mais ça n'est pas
vraiment les effets comme d'ailleurs
pour les vaincus il ya beaucoup d'effets
audio l'a fait beaucoup plus de temps
cette vidéo là que vous êtes en train de
regarder par exemple pour mon ami très
peu de temps le voit vraiment par contre
celui est à fond derrière
donc voila mais ça dépend vraiment des
vidéos le temps de montage mais c'est
eux mêmes qui font finalement c'est une
petite fourchette basse à dépensent en
moyenne c'est une journée que l'on voit
tu ne t'es retour sur les modifs voilà
après pour les plus compliqués massa
mais m une journée plus quoi en général
ça dépend
mais c'est vraiment ça dépend vraiment
du boulot contrariété les gens que tu
cites nouveau les textos dar al zahra
monique we ll t'embrasser elle ne se
n'y arrive pas non non non pas pour le
tutoiement
ah bah c'est vraiment ça me fait plaisir
voilà après la science de rien qu'ils
demandent et si non tu penses pas du
dernier star wars 1 oui nous reste
vraiment pas assez de temps juste par
antec loyers qui confirme je suis très
rapide mais efficace maintenant tu
parles pas de tout ce qui doit te j'en
profite pour saluer lors là pour le coup
de façon complètement premier degré pour
saluer zoé way et vous ne saurez pas
peut-être peut-être qu'ils sont tous ça
c'est ma fille
voilà ya un mois et demi parce que roman
est un jeune papa voilà donc si vous
voulez nous renvoyer des petites
grenouilles r ça me donne son adresse
dans la description de la vidéo qu'elle
était la question
après il ya plusieurs années la question
lesquelles je pas répondu laquelle a
répondu le dernier town pas ouf
oui voilà j'ai même pas du tout aimé
mois dont klaus mais monfils don camillo
et au milieu me l'avait tellement
descendu en flèche mais finalement j'ai
presque été
presqu'une l'indulgence pour le film je
m'attendais vraiment à vomir du caca par
les narines et en fait j'ai juste vomi
du vomi donc c'est moindre mal douala et
des conseils pour les étudiants et les
nettoyeurs regard exactement de élise
hasard et la débat et l'isae
tous les étudiants en soins infirmiers
qui me regardent et là bon courage
ensuite ayez conscience que vous avez
peut-être pas forcément faire ça toute
votre vie parce qu on devrais je suis
pas chez moi j'ai fait des reconversions
un peu ubuesque mais c'est quand même
assez rare d'être charmé toute sa vie et
parce que c'est un métier magnifique
indispensable mais extrêmement fatigant
extrêmement pas très bien payé avec très
peu de perspectives d'évolution
financière donc au bout d'un moment ça
use donc bon courage et bon courage
aussi
et puis qu'est ce que je peux vous
donner comme conseil n'oubliez jamais
que vous soigner des gens
voilà je pense que le moment où tu te
dis je vais voir là la gastrectomie de
la chambre 327
il faut tu te remettre en question parce
que tu vas pas avoir une gastrectomie tu
vas voir un patient une patiente qui a
subi une gastrectomie oublie jamais que
dans les lycées des gens que les gens
tu les tiens entre des mains et que tu
ils sont entièrement dépendant de toi
moi il ya et l'aube uni qui demandent
'est-ce que youtube est un métier alors
oui oui youtube est mon métier belles
boutiques de biographies de pita youtube
était son métier youtube est mon métier
alors c'est tient ce jeu comme il nous
reste un peu de temps petite dernière
petite digression youtube et mon métier
youtube ne me permet pas de gagner ma
vie avec les
pub eux qui a avant au milieu pendant à
la fin et c'est donc tout cas les pubs
youtube pour quelqu'un comme moi qui
fais une vidéo par semaine ce qui est
déjà pas mal de ce qui est déjà beaucoup
de boulot parce qu elle de l'écriture de
la recherche raconter n'importe quoi et
c'est tout cas pour quelqu'un qui à 435
milles abonnés qui fait 2 à 300 milles
du but par vidéo une vidéo par semaine
tu peux pas espérer gagner ta vie avec
les tubes you tube en même temps pour
quelqu'un qui fait mon type de contenu
c'est vite fait un job à plein temps ce
que j'ai assez peu de temps pour faire
autre chose à côté
la preuve c'est que la shr faire un
autre projet que du coup je m'obligeais
de un peu ralentir et jongler sur les
vidéos ce qui justifie que parfois tu
fais des partenariats donc j'ai en effet
je vais continuer à en faire à titre
perso quand je fais un partenariat 1
je vais faire un partenariat avec
quelqu'un avec qui je suis raccord au
niveau éthique et des autos et
déontologiques caylar je serai jamais
des trucs avec des charlatans ou des
gens avec qui je suis pas je me sens pas
à l'aise
ensuite je dis ce que je veux c'est à
dire que je fais validé tous mes textes
de vidéo par le partenaire
eksi n'est pas d'accord on ne fait pas
le deal point final je ne sais pas mme
may cry pas mes textes et on ne modifie
pas mes textes
en tout cas éventuellement à la marge
s'il ya une erreur ou un truc qui voit
là mais en tout cas je raconte ce que je
veux ça c'est la deuxième chose est la
troisième chose c'est que vous le savez
toujours de façon claire qu'il ya un
panneau en début de vidéo un panneau en
fin de vidéo et un panneau dans et un
texte dans la description de la vidéo
donc je vois moi c'est sous ces
conditions là que je fais des
partenariats je vais continuer à en
faire potentiellement dans les mois qui
viennent si ça ne suffit pas à faire
vivre parce que parce que mine de rien
c'est quand même précaire comme taf
peut-être que je ferai un tipi j'en sais
rien mais pour l'instant je sais pas pas
à l'ordre du jour par contre oui je vais
continuer à faire des partenariats
vérité c'est dans ta chatte noire in
arms cette ville pas du tout enfin on
peut tous les fers d'entacher ad'entrée
couilles
voilà on va s'arrêter là un dans ton
corps on a fait le tour et un ans après
la question voilà je pense qu'on a fait
le tour un peu ça me regarde et en
retournant à me faisant un petit tour
sur twitter zone b tard
canarus tu aimes tu lire vos
commentaires
moi personnellement offensé buffo est
mignon beaucoup suis fan de stephen king
toc toc toc alors encore une petite une
petite batterie de questions à laquelle
je répondre en une phrase que porte la
contraception masculine
je suis complètement pour et
vivement que ça se développe parfait ton
casque est gay tony est elle semblait
une vidéo sur la migraine
oui pas tout de suite mais un jour oui
avec 81 la médecine avant un fermier non
je veux bien répondre en évacuer ça je
crois que j'ai déjà répondu chacun un
infirmier par dépit non
bonjour nous aimerions une mini série à
propos de la santé qui s'adressera aux
enfants
ça te branche serait en infra j'ai lu
d'affilée mais oui pourquoi pas c'est
beaucoup de boulot donc
mais oui pourquoi pas alors que ses
réponses attend qu'il sorte rey pointe
lisseur très doux il ya vraiment un goût
de gens qui ont trouvé kawaii blog et
hop hop
j'en profite pour saluer mes camarades
de caribous kéké et notamment ceux que
je le connais de mieux alors julien et
valentin est ce que je pense faire
parler la thyroïde un jour peut-être
c'est pas prévu parce que c'est pas mais
oui pourquoi pas la tête bien répondu
pop up
il est 19 heures on est à la main je
propose de clôture est là dessus ouais
et bien je vous remercie toutes et tous
d'avoir été là on se refera ça peut-être
pas dans sous cette forme là peut-être
on parlera effectivement que de vos
questions santé peut-être qu on
alternera les formats coeff a cure ou
question santé peut-être qu'on fera ça
dans mon salon nous également en mode
apéro peut-être que vous invitera des
fois à venir boire l'apéro chez moi si
vous ramenez des trucs peut-être que
l'on pourquoi pas donc merci à toutes et
à tous d'avoir été là merci romain parce
que tu étais que soient les charges mais
écoute comme d'habitude ans comme
toujours avec toi merci sully derrière
là derrière la console que vous ne voyez
pas mais que vraiment magnifique
et puis qu'est ce qu'on peut vous dire
eh ben on peut vous dire à très bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo genre à mercredi
prochain par exemple voilà
mettez vous bien et puis portez vous
bien
bye
[Musique]